le standard alsace a en retour remarqué
au salon de l'agriculture
mais qu'en pensent les gens enquête
alors que pensez vous du retour de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace dans ce
salon et de son impact
excellent merci le salon de
l'agriculture c'est aussi beaucoup de
nouvelles tendances
le savamment négligé ce 2020 boucle
sauvage
on assume ses cheveux gris
la cinquantaine pimpante la choucroute
une bonne choucroute bon chez nous dans
le nord en bout avec une bière chez vous
si avec un bon verre de la nasa ce ter
alsace est aussi un stand romantique où
il se passe des choses où on conquiert
des femmes avec de la nourriture
et ça marche à manger boire faire la
fête
voilà on va vous prendre en ambassadrice
du tourisme en alsace
monique elle fait la teuf tous les aléas
et biesheim on est bien entouré
l'aquitaine déguste dépôt à mais ça
c'est gergo kis aux six ans après on est
bien entouré du saucisson de vosgiens
n'est ce pas alors pourquoi ils vont
venir en séjour dans votre ferme auberge
parce que on n'y trouve que des bons
produits naturels le paysage est
magnifique l'ambiance du tonnerre de la
vraie vie ce duo savez quoi faire l'été
prochain arrêtez d'aller à ibiza fait un
truc utile et chaleureux vive l'alsace